[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth help them do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships you can give us a
call the number Isle 8825 5225 my name
is Jade warshaw I am joined by George
Campbell good to have you in the house
George so fun it's great because look we
both have books out that's an exciting
time I love it if you're not watching uh
YouTube on podcast we have them both
displayed George's new book Breaking
Free from broke pre-order today and then
you've got this one well George you're
supposed to announce mine I announ and J
warshaw's new book money's not a math
problem there can I say my wife saw your
cover yesterday and she was like that's
such a cute cover oh my gosh I was like
you didn't say that about my cover so I
just want you to know Whitney's a big
fan of the cover she loves the color she
loves your outfit I love that it's
supposed to look like a magazine and I
feel like do you feel like it does 100%
yes and I M looks like Honey I Shrunk
the Kids but you know that's F oh I was
going to go more for like incredible
Hulk like move these walls like I get
that a lot the if I had a nickel Jade
for every time I got compared to the
Hulk I'd be broke real talk I love it
but you can get your copy I would say
just go on and get both of them read
them both or take one for yourself and
give one as a gift that's a good
strategy love it Ramy solutions.com
that's right Ramy solutions.com store to
get it get involved people I'm going to
get involved with these phone lines
we've got Chris from minap olis
Minnesota what's going on Chris hey how
you doing doing good
hi yeah hi I'm I'm on here just to to
find out I have a makeup on location um
business for bridal parties and I
started a wholesale uh brand um from
this I from my makeup on location cool
and I'm looking to scale um and figure
out how to do wholesale for boutique
stores I have 11 locations right now
where I'm selling to boutique stores um
my brand but I'm just trying to figure
out how to how to figure out wholesale
from Consignment doing it Consignment or
selling it um wholesale directly to the
to the boutique stores and to see what's
best so it's your line of makeup it's
your line of makeup that you're selling
yeah well it's private labeled currently
um we're looking at different ways to do
custom stuff cuz I know a lot of
customers are asking for that um with
the movement in the industry of having
things be homemade and when you say
custom when you say custom what does
that mean for makeup cuz let me tell you
what I have in my head because I want to
make sure the listeners understand I'm
thinking the same way I might go to the
drugstore and buy like uh Revlon right
brand you've got your own brand of
makeup that you're selling yep it's a
well privately well so when I say own
brand I work with a manufacturer here in
the US um so it's not my own recipe so
it would be it would be something that I
go there find out what I want to sell
them uh sell through my online store and
the stores yeah and then I I package it
here uh you slap your own label on yeah
I got it y so yeah exactly y make our
boxes here in
Minneapolis okay what are you what are
you bringing in right now what's your
Topline
Revenue um well that's where this so uh
my wedding business where we do makeup
on location is actually the top Revenue
two-part business so that is where
because it's a service industry there's
a low overhead right right that's and I
love that by the way yeah so and so
where the whole brand came from is I had
Bridal clients were like oh you know how
do I catch up you know I need my own car
in the day and that's where the brand
idea came from my brand of gun powder
and gloss Beauty and uh and uh yeah have
some stores that are that want to carry
this yeah they're actually already
carrying it um I have 11 locations right
now I just got Delaware which are pretty
cool I'm trying to basically small
boutique stores that don't have
necessarily A brand like I want to be
able to have the you know powder
foundation all the different things yeah
right now our category mix is just
lipsticks Shadows bronzer like just so
are you not is the problem that you're
selling it to these stores people are
buying it and you're not making any
money is that what the problem is I feel
like I feel like the wholesale piece I
like for instance I'll get a wholesale
ordered it may be you know $300 but then
I buy the goods and it's costing me uh
$300 to buy you know the the product um
the cost of the product and the box and
all the things so I'm just trying to
figure out because I have one store
right now I'm testing this to do
Consignment with them and it's in
Tennessee actually it's um over in
Johnson City in Irwin over in that area
okay and uh it's actually been good like
we have a a 70 to uh 20 split I take 70
she keeps 20 she has no in over like
investment into the into it sure it's
just what you make is what you make
right forgive my ignorance where's the
where's the other 10% going I'm just
curious oh sorry 30 I okay I was like
something is adding up here okay sorry
yeah 70 30 I feel like it's in a lot of
ways it's kind of like a basic math
problem right you you've got to start
with some margin in mind and if there's
no margin then some there's a dollar
amount that's got to shift either on the
cost that you're selling it to them or
on the cost that they're selling it to
the consumer so some of that ends up
back in your pocket right right right so
could you just increase what you charge
for the
wholesalers I could I just feel like in
the beauty industry you know when they
can go into Walmart per se and buy A5
lipstick mine is a you know it's a good
quality lipstick you know no paramid all
the different things that we try to not
have in there um but I sell it for 24
and they may so I'm really trying to
figure out like how do I so probably
what's happening is it a lot of times
what I see is it's like okay like I'm
wearing a hoodie sweatshirt right that I
made if I were to buy this in bulk and
get you know tens of thousands printed
it's a lot cheaper than if I go and say
hey I just need to run a 10 right I'm
I'm paying so much more per item so it
almost sounds like because you're trying
to move small and you're trying to do
this yeah you are going to spend more
per product early on because you don't
have the proof of purchase to just go
out here and say you know what I'm going
to go to this manufacturer and I'm going
to have them do 10,000 lipsticks and
10,000 you know foundations and you're
not there yet and I think the good thing
is right now you are you're going to
have to pass on some of that to the
consumer and you're going to have to
pass on some of that to your distributor
because everybody wants to make money
right if you're not making money you're
not going to keep doing this and if the
manufacturer you know if if the store is
not making money they're not going to
keep uh carrying your brand so what I
would try to do is make sure the value
proposition is there for the customer
why am I going to spend $24 on on
Chris's brand of lipstick when like you
said I can go over to Walgreens and get
one for $5 well you just sold it to me
because I'm like yeah I don't want any
parabens I don't want any uh animal
products in there I don't want you know
I don't want this to make my lips crusty
by the end of the day so make sure
you've just got to get creative with
your branding and understand why this is
better and make sure um the places that
you're reaching out to um to carry this
that is a like it they're known for
carrying Boutique products like that's
there's definitely a market for people
who want that I'm in that market and
it's just this is not the thing to try
to get into uh Walmart or someplace
where they're carrying a lower um price
per item do you know what I'm saying
right but start small try to go
Grassroots try to incentivize the folks
that are buying from you currently to
share spread the word you can give them
free product work with influencers
there's a lot of things you can do
wholesale may not be the ticket for you
there may not be enough profit margin
right nowor so there's a lot of options
out there but I'm proud of you you're
crushing it Chris thanks for the call
thanks for having me on thanks I love
that social media angle George that's
that's where the money is right there J
you're an influencer you understand yeah
I would look I might influence it send
me a couple I want to see if it's any
good this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees every
things backed by their 100% satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40% off everything sitewide go to
blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
[Applause]
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
your host Jade warshaw I joined by
George camel and we want to take your
calls today we want to hear about your
life your money you can even call we'll
talk about your career your
relationships because here's the thing
it all filters together right George one
thing bleeds into the next which bleeds
into the next so give us a call the
number Isle
88255 225 and we would be happy to give
you our take on that um the question of
the day today is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
with 19 service Brands Nationwide
neighborly provider network has trusted
local service professionals to handle
multiple different services in and
around your area visit neighbor.com
Ramsey to find the to find and schedule
your service today today's question
comes from Jeremy in Kansas I'm
struggling to pay off debt not because I
can't afford to but because it's hard
for me to let go of the cash that's in
the bank I have approximately $80,000 in
car loans and $450,000 on my mortgage I
have liquid cash of $400,000 and
brokerage of
$200,000 I know it makes no sense to
keep the debt but I have a hard time not
seeing all of the cash available how do
I overcome this
mentality that's a real question Jade
that's that's a real feeling it is a
real a lot of people when they've got
all this money in the bank it hurts
because they've worked so hard to save
up this money and they feel like they're
making a mistake by deploying it all to
pay off debt that's right but they're
not they're forgetting what's on the
other side of that math yeah you if you
owe $400,000 and you have $400,000 in
the bank that $400,000 is spoken for
that's right by that mortgage company
yep you're not actually free you don't
actually have this giant pile of money
cuz they want their $400,000 yeah you're
not going to get away from it so part of
it is realizing the reality of it's
really not my money it's got someone
else's name on it and until they're paid
I'm not truly free yeah you know I think
the hard part is uh so much of what we
teach is not based on math right it's
based on Behavior it's based on
uh a feeling of Freedom this is one that
is based on math like the math said like
if you it's a it's almost its own net
worth equation there right because it's
like okay you've got all this money you
don't really have $600,000 that you
think you have you've got $520 because
of this debt and wouldn't it be nice to
have all you know wouldn't wouldn't it
be nice for the math to truly math and
you'd be like you know what yes this
money is all mine the money that I have
is all mine but as long as he's got that
debt lay around it's in his head that
okay like 80,000 goes to my car and then
if we pull the mortgage into it then
he's negative actually yeah if he were
to take this money and pay off his
mortgage basic math says he's got 400
liquid cash 200 in The Brokerage that's
600,000 he could okay so he liquid so he
could still have 7,000 left over after
paying off his home after paying off all
these car loans yeah and by the way if
you want to do math buddy that car is a
depreciating asseto that $80,000 loan
well that's now going to be on a $50,000
car you're underwater on and I know that
because we take these calls every day on
the show so if I'm you I'm paying it all
off and still I'm going to have 70,000
left over and that's going to feel great
what are you doing with 400,000 in the
bank just sitting there doing nothing
for you I think people just like to see
it like you log into your bank account
and you just like to see that number go
up but that could also be kind of a
scarcity mentality where there's just
kind of this hoarding of like it'll
never be enough oh 100% that may be that
may be a therapy situation more than a
financial one that's also true I mean I
can if you never had money growing up
you all a sudden see all these zeros in
your bank account and it gives you a
sense of security yes which is great but
you also got to live your life you got
to live your life part of that is having
no debt and there with in his case this
is great because it's a mortgage that
he's paying off this is a forced savings
account so it's not like he's not losing
the money he's just shifting it over to
another place if you really want to
think about it like that that's true
Jade you know people dog me for paying
off our mortgage early because they went
that's so dumb that he paid off a low
interest mortgage early do you know what
he done he could have invested that
money and I'm going y'all don't pay my
bills okay and they don't sleep in your
bed at night that's that is for sure
only my dogs get to do that and my wife
of course she's there too thank you
she's there too but there's a piece of
this equation where you don't know what
that freedom is like to not have to pay
a lender next month and the month after
that and theth the options we now have
to invest way more yeah we're going to
be okay we'll be multi-
multi-millionaires but in the meantime I
want to have no mortgage payment oh so
what you're saying is for them it's a
case of they don't know what they don't
know they've never had they've never
owned a house free and clear so they
really can't speak to the feeling that
it gives you when when the mortgage is
and like Dave always says hey go pay it
all off and if you miss the debt you can
always go get more of it there you go so
try it out Jeremy I'm proud of you man
you're you're crushing it and you could
clear all this debt today and being baby
step seven living and given like no one
else highly recommend it good stuff
let's see what Haley from Hartford
Connecticut's talking about what's going
on in your world
Haley hi Jade hi George how's it going
we're doing well how are you doing fine
um so I'm asking on behalf of myself and
my husband um we're wondering should we
sell our house if we think it was a
mistake to buy it well what's you what's
making you think it was it could be a
mistake okay so we bought our house 6
months ago um and we started listening
to ram
four months ago um funny how that works
really right perfect timing um but
basically we um we didn't really think
it through we didn't have a budget we
didn't you know we didn't follow any of
the baby steps yet and our house is 34%
of our monthly
take-home uh pay yeah and of it's just
we did buy it under market price so we
could sell it for a little more more
than we bought it so we could make um I
just met with our real Tri and we
actually could walk away with about 9 to
18 Grand based on what it sells
for um so we're wondering should we just
you know we haven't been in our house
very long but should we just you know
kind of have no shame in saying hey this
was a mistake let's go back to renting
and let's pay off the rest of our debt
with the money that we make well let's
see how much how much debt do you have
um so we have about so we we're in baby
St 2 we have our um our emergency our $1
th000 emergency fund and then um we are
paying off we had 10,000 in credit card
debt and 18 on a car so the 10,000 in
credit card debt um over the past month
we've brought it down to um 2,000 oh
great or 8,000 we brought it down 2,000
to 8,000 oh it's 8,000 so 8,000 in
credit card debt yep and 18 on the car
okay what
else um that's it what's the household
income um so
our like before taxes or after taxes
just gross annual income before taxes
okay so I make um 48,000 and my husband
makes 62 Okay so we've got a little over
100,000 gross and you're saying 34% is
going to the mortgage then we've got all
these debt payments uh I don't think
this is like an on fire sell the house
tomorrow situation but I would try to
increase income for both of you even
that's temporary for the side hustle cuz
I want you out of debt you got 26 Grand
to pay off
now um yeah could you do that in like
six months if you got real
intense yeah so we're doing instacart
and like um what's the dog dog sitting
Rover um and but we're talking over four
grand a month going toward the debt
that's aggressive right now you're doing
about two so we need to double that I
agree and if you can pay this off fast
that'll free up some income and if you
can get keep that income up that will
lower the amount of your take-home pay
going towards the house now all of a
sudden we can breathe and this house
becomes a blessing instead of a burden
cuz I mean a long term I mean we we
recommend that your home obviously is no
more than 25% you're at 34 you have to
ask yourself what do I need to do to get
to find that 9% over the Long Haul and
what does that look like and it's a lot
but it's not a lot you know what I mean
can you can you find another $110,000 a
year can you find another $122,000 a
year like what does that look like you
may not want to do instacart and Rover
forever but how can you get your core
income up 9% and I think if you guys put
your heads together and figure out what
that looks like that's really the ticket
solving this equation and I would sell
that car before the house if we're
getting to some Dire Straits and you're
feeling the pinch I like that so there's
an option can I ask a followup question
make it quick okay so what if we don't
like the house very much oh my goodness
that's a whole different question that's
a whole different question you may end
up selling I just don't want you to
think this is a fire because of the
finance side but that's right this is
why we tell people only buy when you're
ready that's right don't get pressured
into it one thing at a time pay off that
debt try to get your income up and then
we'll fry bigger fish when we get to it
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
[Applause]
more
you are listening to the ramsy show I am
your host Jade warshaw joined by George
camel your other host for this hour uh
give us a call the number is 8825 5225
we'll talk about the things that are on
your mind concerning your money maybe
it's the holidays coming up uh I read a
stat George that said the average family
of four uh plans on spending about
$1,651
$1,651 on Christmas just gifts or like
food everything travel that's everything
which when you really think about
especially if you think about travel in
the mix I'm like that's not bad but what
I what I did draw from that is if you're
not on a budget that will go that and
more will go very quickly cuz I'm like
if you're traveling to Grandma's house
and you're cooking you know Christmas
dinner and you've got two kids that
you're buying gifts for and if you're
traveling and there's cousins and things
like that can get out of control very
very quickly and you start to shop for
yourself too I do that's a dangerous
game it is a danger while I'm here it's
on sale might as well okay James in the
booth L here's a poll for you when you
go Christmas shopping do you do one for
them one for me one for them James is
too self one for me do you do that or do
you just like no I'm sticking to at the
very least do you at least buy one thing
for you let's put it like that I feel
like I at least buy one thing for me
thank you for your honesty Jade you're
looking for some justification here what
do you think James are you asking me
personally or to do a poll like we
day both I mean I try my best to stick
to a budget but it can be tough so you
mean you don't buy another black hoodie
what I have black hoodies to spare J Jam
shopping list is real sad and dark
literally oh boy we got to take a call
let's go to jinny in St Louis Missouri
what's going on
Jenny hi guys um I'm getting married
soon I'm 55 he's 58 he wants to sell his
home and take the 50,000 in gain from
that sale and app it to my home which
has a balance of
$129 um I think the money should be used
differently because I am trying to get
out of debt with some other debts and I
don't know what to do because I
understand why he wants to do that I
just I just want to do it the right way
well it's kind of
weird I was expecting because I was kind
of reading up on your call before we
took it and I was thinking oh probably
he's trying to take the equity out of
his home to pay off her home
but but this doesn't even
clear it no no it'll just be paying
50,000 down off the 129 that's currently
owed to get closer to paying the house
off there's a couple problems with this
um number one you're not married yet so
I would not think of doing anything like
this or anything else with your money
together until after you're married
right yes yes it it's all going to
happen after the fact okay that gives us
some peace so is the idea what's the
idea because now you both have homes
your married what are you guys
attempting are you trying to get in a
situation where one of these houses is
paid off and you can rent it no no no
he's going to sell his home and he's
gonna ,000 in equity he's going to apply
to my home balance I see I see and what
is the total debt balance you have not
with the
mortgage I have 19,000 in a car and then
I have a student loan but I can't pay it
off because it's part of a divorce
agreement and we equally pay payments
towards it strange and you can't pay
your balance in full like a lump sum to
cover your section I can't cuz the
loan's in my name and it's kind of a
weird scenario so I that one is 22,000
is that the total amount or is that your
just your half no that's the total if
I'm not going to lie if it's in your
name and I might be like try to get with
the judge and be like can I pay this off
and then he pay me
back we can we could go there I I might
do that simply because it's in your name
I just don't want this hanging around
for 10 more years AC crewing interest
while you're just shipping away it only
has it only has four years left so I
think I think I'm not too worried about
that one well if I were in your shoes if
you guys get if and when you guys get
married i' take the 50k from the sale of
his house I pay off this debt first
including the whole 22,000 and I would
do a situation where it's like hey I
don't like fooling with this guy it's in
my past I'm G to get debt free if you
can make it to where he pays me off
great but I'm moving on with my life
that's what I would do that's what Jade
would do and I think that's what George
would do too yeah and I like just when
you get married then you guys do the
baby steps together and that means how
much money do we have as a couple all
right we got the Thousand starter
emergency fund we have this debt let's
knock this out with whatever cash we
have let's build the emergency fund 3 to
6 months let's start investing and then
any money beyond that we can throw it
the mortgage which may end up being less
I'm worried about our
retirement like position like where we
are and that was another kind of wrench
in this whole picture well that's even
more reason to walk it through this way
because the the faster you clean up this
debt is the faster that you can get 3 to
six months saved is the faster that you
guys can really start focusing on the
things that are going to build you
wealth which are setting aside some
money for retirement and paying off the
your existing home the one that you guys
decide to live in the one with the
129,000 on it okay so you you would
agree with me and getting rid of the
smaller debt first before starting to S
suck away at the house because with that
with just the car being paid off is
another 500 a month that would just go
towards the house well and what's going
to be the household income once you guys
get
married uh bring home to bring home will
be about 6,200 a month awesome that's
great and so how quickly could you pay
off the mortgage once you guys are
married you have no debt we've knocked
down the mortgage a little bit with
whatever cash is left over we're talking
a few years right our goal is five years
or less boom and that would be that
would be my goal we're going to retire
when the house is paid off and over
those five years you're also going to be
investing 15% of your income as soon as
this debts paid off and you have that
emergency fund do you have anything in
retirement right now between the two of
you um between the two of us it's maybe
a little over a h 100,000 but that get a
a pension that covers about 75% of my
income when I retire okay but the big my
bigger my next question if I have time
sure is I have what's called a backdrop
coming when I retire to the tune of 60
to
70,000 it's a lumpsum payment that's
given by the state government for every
year you work past your normal
retirement and then you get your pension
okay um if that money is taxed unless I
roll it over but I was actually when I
was single thinking oh well if I have
anything left on the house at that time
I'll just pay my house off um but how
would you how would you utilize those
funds when do you get
it I I will get it in well I won't get
it till retirement which will be eight
years okay so we'll have a paid for
house so I'd rather roll it and save on
the taxes and use that as part of your
nest
EG and just get it as a monthly monthly
amount kind of thing okay yeah because
by then you're going to be debt-free
including your house so you wouldn't
need to roll it to the house yes and and
like and I was able to work it out so I
could live on my income when I retire so
his income will be just on top of that
gravy on top I think this is a good plan
and most people find that when they have
no payments it's easier to retire even
if you don't have a huge income and a
huge retirement account and so that's
why the focus is on decreasing your
expenses I think that's a good point
George because it's hard we talked about
this earlier it's hard for most people
to imagine a life number one where they
have no Consumer Debt but number two
where they don't have a mortgage I mean
that's for most people that's the
biggest line item next to daycare the
biggest line item on their budget so
imag Imaging a world where it's like hey
when I get my paycheck all the money
like all the money goes to me and when
it's like that when you then step into
these retirement years it's like well I
suddenly need a lot less to live on
because really it's just for those what
your cell phone bill you're telling me
your cell phone bill is what's going to
drain your re Insurance your cell phone
bill and your Paramount Plus
subscription cuz you got to watch I
Carly got have it Jade and you're maybe
you you you get a country club
membership so you can play pickle ball
there we go you know some of the
luxuries of I want to retire and have so
many options I don't want to retire and
be like oh we got to now scrimp because
we didn't save enough and part of that's
getting rid of the mortgage and that's
why we recommend the 15year fixed rate
mortgage yes it's conservative and
aggressive but we found that people who
follow the baby steps who do that end up
paying off their mortgage in seven years
seven years so they're not going into
retirement with a mortgage hanging over
their head and they're figuring out when
can I retire yeah they got options
that's the blink of an eye George and
our millionaire study found 10.2 years
was the average amount of time for
millionaires to pay off their home wow
10.2 years and we also found that the
average millionaire is not someone who's
making over six figures right a third of
them never made six figures teachers
right these are accountants what's the
third one uh Engineers Engineers you go
I like when we debunk the myths right we
demystify it and realize hey it's
actually not crazy at all it's actually
pretty simple it's just this consistent
pattern paying off debt investing 15%
it's almost too boring Jade they want
something more complex and crazy but
that's it that's how it's done that's
how it's done this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you're listening to the ramsy show my
name is Jade horshaw this is George
camel make some noise George woo all
right that's it that's all you get I
wanted him to know that you were there I
wasn't just talking you know the people
on podcast they don't know we could tell
them anything I'm rarely asked to make
some noise I will say that much so I
didn't know what to do there noise well
we're taking your calls about your life
and money give us a call the number is
88255 225 and we'll try to help you out
but uh I do want to tell you guys number
one I'm so thankful for all of the
listeners I'm thankful for everybody who
downloads the podcast everybody who logs
in and checks us out on YouTube it's
it's really just the reason that we're
here is you guys um and we appreciate
your support and if you're looking for
another way to support something you can
do is consider liking subscribing and
sharing the show with your friends your
family your co-workers anybody who you
feel like is broke and needs some help
if you're like wait a minute I noticed
that Joe pulled up in a brand new Lexus
he's got the same paycheck that I have
something's wrong share the show that's
a nice way to do it I love the show you
should check it out yeah Thanksgiving is
coming up you're sitting down at the
table Uncle Boo Boo is talking about
whole life insurance yet again share the
show do you see what I'm saying do you
see the train of thought that I'm on
here like subscribe share when you do
that not only does it help us not only
does it help you it helps other people
right it boosted up in the algorithm
they discover this very very important
resource and they're able to change
their life and money because of it so
consider doing that and we would say
thank you all right let's go to the
phone lines we got Taylor and Kansas
City m o That's Missouri not Kansas all
right what's going on
Taylor hey guys I appreciate the time no
problem how can we help well um my
mother-in-law has recently purchased a
house here in Kansas City where my wife
and I live and uh she she kind of was
hoping you know hey in the future I
might move back um be closer to family
and whatnot and she kind of came to us
and said or not kind of but she did and
said hey you know I think you guys
should live there and um you can live
there rent free uh you know just if you
guys want the house um I just don't want
to deal with a renter um but you can
live their rent free and so we were like
wow uh this gives us an opportunity to
kind of um take our current house that
we live in um and then we were just
wondering like should we do this and
rent out our current house that we live
in um and pay that house off interesting
so your mother-in-law doesn't live there
I know it's a weird is that right is is
an empty
house uh the one that she has yes yeah
she's not living there with you no she
she lives a little over an hour away
what was the purpose of her getting the
house uh just for hopes of possibly
moving back closer to family so in the
future at some point what um what
happens if next you know what happens if
a year and a half from now she's like
I'm ready to I'm ready to move back what
happens then I I think we would just
move back into our current home that
we're in because we don't plan to sell
it okay interesting is a very
interesting predicament um does she have
a mortgage on that
house no okay so it's paid for so she's
still paying insurance and property
taxes is that just her gift to you yeah
and who's responsible of the HVAC
breaks uh so that's that's the kind of
thing we don't really know like I'm
guessing that you would advise us to get
that in writing you know 100% do you see
where I'm going with this though like
all these little nooks and crannies that
we thought life was going to work out
perfectly and now the roof needs to be
replaced and she goes well you guys are
renting for free I feel like you should
cover it I don't like the deal yeah I I
I don't like the deal um because of what
George just said and the here's another
part of it um I feel like when you buy a
when you if you purchase a piece of
property for the purpose of renting it
your heart goes in a different place
you're like whatever it's not my house I
don't it's it's for renting it's to make
a profit when you take what you know
will is supposed to eventually be your
personal residence and you rent it out I
think that it's not the same house
anymore and you're going to be like I
this dude's been in my bathtub like you
it it just feels different and so I
think that taking your home that's been
your home for a while then you go live
in this other house you let renters rent
there for 2 three years and then you
want to go back to it I don't think it's
going to be the same place anymore so
that's my second reason that I'm not
going to say it's I'm not going to say
that it's wrong to do because it's not
wrong but these are just the reasons
that I wouldn't do it what do you think
George yeah I mean we've seen worse
situations on this show if mother-in-law
was living there this would be a
different situation if she had a
mortgage this would be a different
situation so there's just a few red
flags that make me pause and go is this
the right move do you guys really need
the money are you trying to pay off debt
is the mortgage too much for you you
know what's your financial situation
that's driving you to do this other than
hey free rent we could make some money
renting our place now you also become
landlords have the hassle and risk of
having tenants and you're responsible
for you know a lot of the things that
happen in that house right and that's
actually one of the reasons why because
we you I think we would like to
eventually become landlords and so this
is kind of a getyou feet wet scenario
where we don't have a whole bunch
invested and if like something kind of
goes wrong um we still have a place to
live that we're you know doing here's a
wild scenario I just thought of Taylor
what if you got a tenant in your
mother-in-law's house and you guys were
kind of the property managers
interesting oh and maybe she gave you
the majority of the proceeds that way
you're not having to make this George I
just it it's two birds one stone here
you get to taste the the Waters of the
landlord life you get a little bit of
money back you get a little bit of money
back and uh the risk is still on her she
needs to know that and you get to keep
your house but either way the risk was
on her if the roof needs to be replaced
it was either going to be on her or on
her not on you or the tenant so I would
offer that as another scenario versus
uprooting your current life George that
is that's the move I I vote that that is
the move
Taylor okay there we do the there's no
downside and it takes the risk oh
totally off of your plate and it takes
anything that could possibly happen uh
with repairs and all this stuff that
makes those awkward money conversations
right with family where it's like hey uh
you know Grandma we need some money for
the pipes froze you know it's just it's
it takes that away because the more
conversations that you have like that it
just eats into the relationship just a
little bit every single time so I really
George I think that is a winning a
winning solution that was good thanks
Jade at least one time a day I have a
decent idea that was good I'm going to
tell I'm going to tell Whitney about
that I'm going to be like George came
through with a great idea today mark it
put the tally on next to his name uh
what do you think George can we talk to
Julian and San Antonio let's do it
what's going on Julian from San Antonio
Texas hi guys hi to be
on uh well I'm going to get straight to
it um I'm a I'm a police officer from my
County uh I've been there for nine years
uh and I've buil a retirement there
uhhuh now I have an opportunity to go
work as a security guard on security
guard at a school district at a higher
pay rate than what I am getting paid
right now as a police officer uhhuh and
safe I got to
assume yes but I am not so sure if I
should make the jump because my county
has a great retirement system where for
every dollar I put they put two so you
get a a
match yes two for one what's your new
retirement plan going to be it's the TRS
the teachers retirement system uhhuh and
so they just pull a little of your check
and throw it in
there yeah they was explained that it
was years of service times 2.3% times
average
salary how old are you and now 35 and
how much have you put into retirement
thus
far um so far that
I you're breaking up on us Julian speak
right into the
phone oh I'm sorry I have
33,6 77 okay and how much debt do you
have do you have any debt no no debt how
much uh higher paying is this
job well right now I get paid 20 45 an
hour and the other one I possibly be
making $30 an hour okay I'm GNA be
honest with you working somewhere nine
years and you're at 20 bucks I'm taking
this leap man me too and it's
safer it's a safer job and you can make
up for it through retirement you're 35
you got another you know 25 30 years to
start investing and you'll do that since
you don't have any debt I'm this higher
pay your income is your greatest wealth
building tool and so that's going to
supersede this retirement plan my friend
thank you for your service to your
community appreciate I love that I love
that he has the opportunity yeah woo
George that does it for this hour 50%
raise right there it's a good day it it
is a good day I love it that does it for
this hour of the show be sure to hang
with us for next hour it'll be me and
George here with you we'll see you on
the next hour of the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host Jade
warshaw I am joined by George camell to
my right and we are taking there you go
we are taking calls all afternoon about
your life your money your financial
situation your quandries if you will so
give us a call the number is 8825 5225
and we will do our best to help you out
all right let's go straight to the phone
lines we've got Judy May in I'm gonna
say like this Greenville South Carolina
what's going on Judy May yes just to let
you know I have been listening since
Ramsey started wow it's been a long time
I have grandkids that are still using
his principles wow my situation is uh in
June I was in U budel budel motel in
Tallahassee Florida uh couldn't stay the
night because there was prostitution
going on uh in the room next to meik and
there was all kinds of U scary stuff
going on in the parking lot packed with
people I left did not spend the night
couldn't even it wasn't even safe to go
to the desk to camp canel came back the
next morning with family that had spent
the night there and they got their money
back um but they would not give me my
money back because uh I had paid through
budget um a Booking.com and it would
have to go through them I have been
fighting this since June the U hotel has
Motel has now changed hands and the new
owners won't make good on it the old
owners wouldn't make good on it and
they're hanging up on me when I call
is not willing to do anything and the um
credit card company um through Sam's is
been trying to do something and not
getting anywhere I don't know what to do
at this point it's
$290 for one night any recourse
whatsoever wow was this a one night stay
or was this multiple nights it was uh a
three night reservation I didn't even
spend the first night there I got back
to the motel with family that took me to
my OT motel room at 10:00 within a few
minutes I knew that it was only going to
escalate and be worse in the middle of
the night so uh I let my uh um son came
and um took me back to my car so
basically they were they were at the
other end of the motel and it wasn't
quite as effective for them but their
motel room was very dirty mine was at
least not dirty but I couldn't stay
there it wasn't safe so you paid the 290
you want a refund because this place was
terrible and it's frust you that book
that okay what was the name of the hotel
you said Budgetel it was Budgetel it has
now been changed to O yo motel in
Tallahassee so what you're saying to the
public is don't stay at oo motel in
Tallahasse thank you for the PSA nothing
else let me tell you let can I just put
set your mind at ease Judy may you
coming on this radio show and telling
these millions of folks not to stay at
oo is worth more than the
$290 you just you
for that one person who's on booking.com
right now going oh I out yeah so if just
just understand that number one um your
best bet I mean of course you can try
booking.com and try to escalate it a
thousand times up to you know
supervisors and management you can keep
going back to the hotel and explaining
you can go to the credit card company
and and keep trying to get the charge
back those are your three Best Bets here
you can report you know a claim on
Better Business bureau's website and the
business has to respond to that resp
that they don't even they don't respond
to me at all I've tried numerous times
here's the problem at the end of the day
at some point your time is worth
something isn't it yes so at some point
do we go all right listen we've expended
18 hours worth of energy now I get that
the based on principle you you're
willing to fight this thing till your
last breath but there may not be a day
where Judy May gets her full $292 back
unless someone who works at booking.com
goes in the chats and says Judy may
contact me I'll help you out so if you
work at booking.com and you can help her
out or you work at oo and you can help
her out hit up the chats and say Judy
may come holler at me I'll make this
right for you but I agree with George at
some point you've got to just go this is
back in June talk it up to a loss so the
longer the time goes on the harder it's
going to be to get it back yeah so I'm
sorry you're going through this Judy M
that's a real bummer I I'm especially I
get rowdy at bad customer service
situations like that and I'm the guy who
fights for the refund my wife is in the
car going like I can't eat be in that
situation I get it but I get it I look I
would be like her I I hate when
something I forked over my money for
does not turn out the way also cancel
the Sam's Club credit card Judy may come
on you've been listening to us for too
long good call cut that and say hey I'm
cancelling because y'all treated me like
this that's reason number one number two
Dave said no I love it wow wow wow wow
that's crazy um sorry I'm thinking about
that $290 I mean 39
you're ticked off because you're like I
I planned on being somewhere for three
nights she had to stay somewhere else so
that's other money forked away plus a
290 and then everybody's pointing it's
like that Spider-Man thing where they're
all pointing at the other person no it
was him no it was booking.com no it was
O at some point is this worth taking to
small claims court and getting lawyers
involved to try to get this money it's
not probably not it happens to the best
of us we all get in these situations and
at the end of the day you just have to
be like well lesson learned lesson
learned number one book to that's an
important note for a lot of people out
there some of these websites you have
trouble when it's through a third party
I I never use them I almost never use
them and if I do I and this is not a
none of this is plugs or ads for
anything by the way I always go on trip
advisor First Look up the reviews and
look at the reviews and for me it's the
photos when it comes to a hotel I actual
user photos not the one upload actual
user photos that's what I want to see
because they will show you the photos
from the day the hotel was renovated
you know on the actual Hotel you know on
the the actual room you're getting it's
like here's our Sample Room at at Peak
and I want to see I want to know did
anyone find a bug I want to know did
anyone see a hair on their pillow
because all it takes is one that's all I
need to know about and I'm moving on
that's true but you can also when you
when you find the best deal then call
the hotel directly and say hey I found
this deal they'll generally match it
they want your business they don't want
to have to give a cut to the third party
website so little for you guys out there
as you're booking whatever it is you can
uh skip the third party sites and book
direct and tell them hey match this
price and I'll I'll give you my business
I like that hack do you got any more of
that George any more so much travel
hacks out there I mean we could be here
all day talking travel hacks there's a
few good uh you know apps and things
like that that can help you find the
best deals but I found one of the best
ways is you know you want to if you're
booking flights for example there might
be a time when that flight becomes
cheaper and so with Southwest for
example I showed Ken Coleman this and he
instantly saved hundreds of dollars and
he was like thank you so much so if you
book a Southwest flight for $300 next
week it may be $200 so if you go in and
you rebook on Southwest for that same
flight don't cancel it just change it
rebook that same flight you'll get the
$100 back in credit or to your card so
it's not you booking an additional
flight and then going and canceling the
other one it's you taking that existing
flight rebooking it that's it or is
Southwest the only one that does that
that's the one I've used there may be
others that do it but it's an easy way I
wish they would just tell you hey the
flight is cheaper and we're going to
refund you the difference that would be
really nice I mean that would be really
nice if I owned an airline that's what I
would be doing Jade so we got to stay on
top of it is what you're saying you got
to stay on top of what you're spending
the best hacks always have some effort
involved but they're always worth it oh
I love it I hate what happened to Judy
may but sad it happens to the best of us
thanks for the hacks George thanks for
the tips to save money this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your healthc care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that is helped members take
care of nearly $1 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at CH ministries.org
[Music]
budget
you are listening to the ramsy show I am
Jade warshot your host I'm joined by my
co-host Today George camel George by the
way you have a new book out am I correct
is true yes it's on pre-sale right now
it's called Breaking Free from broke J
you're like the van white over here here
it is I got it ready I'm excited about
this this is my experience following the
baby steps for 10 years going from broke
to millionaire and helping so many
people avoid the traps some of them I
fell for and some of them I've helped
other people avoid um including credit
scores credit cards student loans auto
loans mortgages investing traps I break
it all down with research humor empathy
hopefully some wisdom and then I show
you how to break free from that toxic
system um and it's it's a really fun I
tried to make this like candy while
putting some meat on the bones at the
same time put some meat on the bones so
I'm excited about it you really slid by
the fact that you went from broke to
millionaire I mean you just said that
like like it wasn't a how fast did you
do that that took a decade and so this
wasn't overnight there was no life hacks
I literally this is so boring Jade I
just followed the baby steps I got out
of my Consumer Debt it was $40,000 in
debt yes started in you know my got my
emergency fund started investing for the
future and my company 401K I met my
lovely bride Whitney who works here we
got married completely debt free we had
a big down payment we paid off our house
real early and all of a sudden you just
look up and you add the numbers and you
go we have a household net worth of over
a million dollars in our early 30s I
like it so I just want to show people I
didn't come from money you know my job
here at Ramsey was not personality up
until a year or two ago so people go
he's making a million dollars I was not
and I am not uh but you know Dave if
you're out there listening make it
happen so I just want to show people
that it's still possible in America
today even as difficult as it feels with
today's economy and the housing market
and all the reasons you could say I'm
not going to get ahead with money it's
possible the little man can get ahead
and this book proves it I love that and
you know what 10 years 10 years you can
see that as oh my gosh that's such a
long time but in my mind when we're
talking about net worth millionaire
status that is so short the time the
time that you accomplish that George so
very good well part of it is having a
spouse that's on board so I know that's
that's a big piece of it and you and Sam
that was a big piece of your story
paying off over a million and I'm
excited to tell people about your brand
new quick read coming out December 5th
Jade you beat me to the punch let me get
it right here called money is not a math
problem boom and uh you uncover All The
Lies We tend to believe when it comes to
money and budgeting and you help us uh
get the right mindset around it cuz we
know personal finance 20% knowledge 80%
behavior all day so it's not really
about the numbers at the end of the day
it's about your behavior and mindset and
you share your story in this book and
you help others get on the plan and
what's cool is with both of these books
if you pre-order you get three months of
the premium version of every dollar
totally free if you're a new user so
whether you get Jade's or mine uh you
get those free three months and we got
all kinds of pre-sale assets to convince
people to buy and I say it's the
holidays I say go on ahead and pick them
up pick up both of them yeah mine's 20
bucks to pre-order yours is 10 buckss so
30 bucks all in and you got some life
change on your hands life change on your
hands yes I love that and we're younger
and more energetic than day well maybe
not more energetic that guy can outrun
me on a on a bad day but I think we
bring a useful we bring a youthful
energy we do to our books and to what we
do and I think if you got younger people
in your life Millennials Jen Z you know
this is the book for them and we have
hair so there you go all right let's
head it straight to the phone lines we
got JD and Seattle Washington what's
going on JD hi thank you for taking my
call uh speak directly into your phone I
had a hard time hearing you there can
you hear me better I can what's going on
so recently I lost my grandfather and
about a week later my grandmother was in
a really bad car accident I had to fly
across the country yeah to facilitate
like the funeral and then I moved my
grandmother into assisted living um and
also just finished selling their house
to actually Clos this week um my my
mother is fully dependent on my
grandparents financially and with the
profits from the sale of their house my
grandma wants to use uh the money to buy
my mother a small condo now I her power
my grandmother's power attorney for a
lot of things I'm worried about U my
mother's Financial irresponsibility and
if we buy something for her and her name
or if we do probate there may be some
issue or if we put in my grandmother's
name we go through probate later on that
may lead to some issues so my main
concern is uh my sister and I want
cannot financially have the capability
to support my mother down the line so
try trying to get advice as to what you
think would be the best route especially
with getting her a
so when your grandmother sells her house
and goes to Assisted Living how much
what's the take home off the sale of the
house so we got um they made around 200
and over 200,000 from it and of which um
I my grandmother her assisted living is
paid for okay I was going to ask by by
pension and my concern is her my
grandmother's pension um covers just her
assisted living and no additional
expenses
and won't increase over her the rest of
her life okay so the pension is just
enough to cover her stay there it
doesn't account for anything else
correct and what are what are some other
potential Co um expenses that you see
with her stay at I could could see in
the future her going into memory care if
you know if that's necessary um I sadly
live on the other side of the country my
sister does does as well and my mom is
just not really capable of helping so
what would it look like if we took this
200,000 and we parked it somewhere and
we said this is this is money to take
care of grandma aside from the pinion
because if you if you foresee that you
need that money it feels like that's
maybe the better use of this and then
you know when grandma's when Grandma
goes to heaven whatever money is left
you guys can decide is that used to help
Mom buy a condo now or what do we do
with that I that was my first instinct
too however my mom would not have a
place to live um before my grandfather
passed they were paying for not only her
rent but her living
expenses
why she um many years ago um she never
was able to fully I guess recover from
my their her divorce from my father and
um when her alimony finished when I
turned 21 and I'm now 24 uh she never
got back on her feet fully when you say
recover is this just a financial thing
or is there anything else in involved in
that Rec is she disabled
physically she is not um she's not it's
just she's had a very hard time finding
a job to stick to is one way of putting
it how old is
she she's in her uh early 60s what
happens if she lives to be in her 90s
who's going to cover the tab for the
next 30 years yeah that's one of my my
big worries as well I think we need to
help Mom get on our feet even if it's
difficult because that's the best
long-term plan for her aside from the
situation with Grandma's money and do we
buy her a condo this feels like just
more enabling and I want to give your
mom some Dignity of having a life and
having some purpose to get up every
day yeah we've we've tried to work on
that too um with her so I guess it's
just uh the reality I find myself in is
accepting the state kind of and not
really knowing how to best well is your
mom GNA be way is your mom going to live
on the streets if you don't buy her a
condo or do do you have faith that she
will figure out I have faith she'll
probably figure out a living situation
whether it's renting a place on her own
or figuring out a roommate situation if
she can't afford to live on her own um
there's part of this where uh the cord
kind of has to be cut or she's got to
get kicked out of that Nest so to speak
and it's like hey you've got to figure
out how to land on your feet because
it's not just that we're trying to be um
rude or ugly or mean to you but we've
got to take care of grandma and we don't
have that much it's it's not like we're
talking about a million bucks sitting
here it's $200,000 which can be gone
licky split um and may not even be you
know what I'm saying like there's
there's bigger fish to fry in this
situation so when you go to your
grandmother and you say to her grandma I
know what you want to do and I know
you're trying to be generous but we we
don't even have enough money to fully
take care of you we need to keep this
money to take care of you um during your
your final years does she have the
wherewithal to understand that at this
point she does yeah she's very um she
wants she knows my how my mom is how
irresponsible she is and and I do think
that she would you know that's a concern
of mine like you mentioned earlier what
does she do yeah buying this condo is
just a Band-Aid it doesn't actually fix
the problem and there's going to be more
expenses and there's no more money now
Grandma's out of money and can't support
her that's right so we've got to figure
out a different solution I'm sorry JD
you had to grow up real fast man at 24
to be handling all this I'm proud of you
and I'm sorry all at the same time yeah
get with a smart Vestor Pro and get that
200,000 invested so that you guys can
use it for her care this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level Nets gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us netw week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them SM marter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
your host Jade warshaw joined by your
other host George camel and we have been
given permission to get wild and crazy
George really yes from who will Rudder
who's over there in the production Booth
I'm calling him I'm naming names will
this is the Ramsey Show give us a call
the number Isle 8825 5225 we try to have
a good time in between taking your calls
about your life and money um so do give
us a call try to get in there get in
that queue and we will hear from you and
try to help you as best we can but in
the meantime uh George I find this to be
very interesting uh from time to time
they pull some articles and want us to
kind of react to it and talk about it
and I love this one it says new American
tipping culture is confusing
frustrating A study finds I thought
there was going to be one more adjective
there was it felt like it was going to
be a trio they really let me down
watching I was trying to do a Johnny
Cochran moment and it failed but the
state of tipping in America is in a word
a mess Americans are divided and
Confused over when to leave gratuities
and how much to tip for all kinds of
services according to a new study
published Thursday by Pew Research
Center many don't like recent Trends
such as these added service fees and
suggested tipping amounts uh tipping is
one of those things in American society
where there just aren't clear rules they
said there's not a single General
accepted way of doing things like with
traffic lights where we all know that
red means
stop we call it tipf flation
George yeah people are just the
consumers are just expected to pay
gratuities 72% say tipping is expected
in more places today than it was 5 years
ago part of that is due to technology
right I mean you see the iPad they can
just add this into the software bada
bing bada boom they don't have to pay
the workers as much because the consumer
gets to take on the brunt of that w
increase well the worst part is Where I
Come
From I'm talking about food specifically
and service where I come from you need
to get a chance to see if you need a tip
right like you need a chance to see was
it good I of course you go to a
restaurant let's be clear you go to a
restaurant you must tip like the the
minimum is 15% out of restaurant but if
you did a great job I'm going above and
beyond I love tipping at restaurants but
if I go to a place uh like the coffee
place I went to the other day which will
remain you're standing in line you get
to the counter I haven't even it yet and
then they go this just going to ask you
a few questions I don't even know did
you get the order right and let me tell
you what happened the other day right
quick I go to a coffee store which shall
remain nameless place my my
order sit down get the
order and I had ordered a smoothie and I
said um may I have a straw please she
said we don't have many straws I said
well how am I supposed to drink the
Smoothie she goes you could use a spoon
oh and I said well I wish you had told
me that before I ordered it cuz I would
have ordered something different she
rolled her eyes at me I said oh no she
didn't how can you run a coffee shop and
not offer straws how you going to roll
my eyes at my eyes how you going to roll
your eyes at me when I just gave you my
hard-earned money I don't want to be on
that side of Jade wara I'm just saying
so you see what I'm saying if I had
tipped first I would have been right
back there and like let me have my give
me my $5 back cuz you eye rolled at me
yeah that's a tough one for sure um
there's a and it's there's a lot of
confusion too people we I think we all
want to be decent good human beings
we're not trying to be you know jerks
and stingy but at some point we have to
just go I'm not going to tip for when I
it didn't require a tipping situation no
I got my own frozen yogurt I put it in
the cup myself check out somebody self
checkout asking for a tip you order
something online a piece of furniture
and it's like hey you want to tip the
crew yeah no you have to build in their
their own income into the product that
you're selling me yeah but it feels so
silly that it's gone Way Beyond just a
service hospitality situation and more I
think the I think the most um the the
craziest part is it's that it's before
the fact I think that more Industries
probably could ask for tips like I'm not
mad for saying hey did you like your
service show show us you appreciate us
but can you just please do it at the end
can you do it after the fact that's for
me that's really where the differential
is is let
meice it's now gone up it starts at 20
and then it goes up 30
50% no and some coffee shops have just
started doing you want to tip one Buck
three bucks or five bucks yeah and like
my order they show you the percentage my
order was $2 yeah cuz they they they're
playing with your psychology you go oh
$1 that's not a lot or five bucks that's
not bad but when you look at the
percentage on something that was it
could have been a 38% tip that's right
yeah this if you tip on to go orders
what's your take on to go if it's a if
it's a to go order that I have to that I
still have to get out of my car and go
in and pick it up I probably won't tip
much cuz I'm like I did everything like
you didn't do much different now if it's
one of the car services where it's like
I just pull up and you bring it out I'll
tip on that that's fair like I'll tip
extra on that because I'm like if I
still have to get out of my car and go
in I'm still do like you're still doing
the most there's a lot now I will say
somebody told me they were like well
Jade they have to put it in the boxes
and they have to do that I'm like but
they were going to put it on a plate are
you telling me card board you can't more
on GL plate I'm just saying everyone's
going to be upset at you but you know we
love generosity what I hate is force
generosity which is very very different
that's right and at the end of the day
there's a lot going on because we've got
inflation right and then there's the
fact that you're choosing to go off site
like go out of your home and get food
anyway so you're paying more and then
you add the tip on top of something that
you were like hey I was trying to go the
cheap route like there's a reason that
we didn't go to Chili's cuz I didn't
want to do a tip right and now that's
why I'm doing takeout is cuz I don't
want to sit there and get service and
then have to pay an extra 15% and that
used to be a tip of saying hey I'm just
going to do takeout instead of sitting
into the restaurant and now they're T
they're taking it away from us GE the
latest one I got a health fee added to
my bill at a restaurant nice restaurant
and it said healthy and so I looked into
it and said hey you're you're supporting
the health care for the workers here I
well that's the employer's job to cover
healthare if that's what they want to do
interesting so they're subsidizing it
through the consumers that's interesting
no what a time to be alive it it doesn't
make sense I'll tell you right now I
will always tip when I get my nails done
always because it's absolutely important
to do that I will always tip when I go
to a restaurant because it's absolutely
important to do that I will always tip
uh the Instagram or not Instagram in
heart Uber you know people who deliver
your groceries someone who went to
Costco on a Saturday for me yeah and
went to my house and brought me my 32
pack of water you know they're getting a
tip yeah cuz I order you know you got
boxes of pull-ups like expensive like
heavy things and I kind of live out in
the Boondocks so it's like you're
driving on these crazy roads that's
commitment you know but like to play
Devil's
Advocate why like why are those things
just default you tip them like do you
tip your your like guy that changes your
oil change like he he did a service
that's what I mean like it's so arbit
where do you draw the line well lucky
for you James we have a fantastic
article on our website called how to tip
in all situations and it's a very
helpful guide and right in there
stitched in is a YouTube video I did on
tipping so we will link that in the show
notes in description wherever you're
watching so you can go check out that
article but it it's a very uh in-depth
article and it goes through situations
where you may tip and maybe you don't
need to tip well to James's point I kind
of think where it started is if you're
you're you're on a wage right a small
salary that they pay you and it's just
kind of known hey this salary is low you
really are working on tips so I think I
think I've just kind of felt that okay
if you're let's say you're a hairdresser
you might be in one of those situations
where you're paying rent to own that
Booth right and so then the money that
comes like if you do my hair part of
that fee goes to the the owner of
whatever and so yeah my thought is like
okay like you're not you're probably
really not earning much off the $60 that
you're costing for my hair let me tip
just to make sure same thing with nails
it's like I think there's just you kind
of know okay they're probably not making
like I I feel like I have to fill in the
Gap same thing with servers at a rest
interesting but James has a good point I
mean I just tipped my barber today Jade
I don't know if you can tell yeah but I
didn't tip the guy who did the oil
change you know why is that that was
that's a Hands-On job look they should
have gotten in when the getting was good
back in the ' 80s that's true time to
switch careers back in the 70s when when
we set the rules they should have well
at the end of the day it's exhausting
and always tip when you can but never
feel like you're forced to do it at that
point you're not doing it for the right
reasons anyways when you're forced to
tip on the screen the 20% button yeah so
skip it with a smile and say have a good
day that's right and there's no shame in
that game no shame no shame whatsoever
and you know this is my favorite time of
year the holidays are my favorite time
of year to do an extravagant tip ooh
you've never done it and you can afford
to do it go out to dinner have a normal
dinner and then just leave $100 extra in
that little envelope and try to get
their reaction this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
this is the ramsy show I am Jade horshaw
joined by George camel please give us a
call the number is 8825 5225 we'll talk
about what's concerning you by way of
your money what are you perplexed by
what is causing you to feel distraught
what is keeping you up at night we want
to talk about those things help you work
through it help you walk through it
let's go straight to the phone lines we
have idam she is in bat and Rouge
Louisiana what's going on
idam hi uh thank you for taking my call
so recently me my husband and my animal
old we moved from Florida to Louisiana
and we're been renting because we were
not able to tour any places sure and so
we found a place that is it was really
nice the rent is really cheap but for
the past 3 weeks we have this neighbor
that smokes marijuana which we have
nothing against it but it's just so
strong gets in her clothes yes get in
the house your baby like he wakens up in
the middle of the night so we're
struggling yeah so we're struggling
between paying out this contract which
is around
$1,200 and move to a different apartment
or by house and is it let me or just
it's legal there
right so it's for medicine purposes
legal and we already talked to the
Landers we they already had a meeting
with the U narcotic police and there's
nothing they can do I think yeah because
shoot they won't move you to a different
unit uh probably know why not we have to
pay out the contract well they for what
they're saying there's just nothing they
can do we already have like three
different calls with them and they're
just it's really simple what they can do
they move you to a different unit at no
charge you're not breaking the lease
you're still a renter
there I would fight them and say I got a
baby here this is a medical situation
for my family now that puts us at risk
and in danger and so we don't want to
make this any more difficult than it has
to be all we're asking is that you move
us to a different unit is that simple
uhhuh and if they get funky fresh I'd
get funky fresh by starting to make
threats about getting my lawyer involved
exactly because that was my next
question like if they are like literally
there's nothing else like moving us to a
different apartment like I don't know if
I I will lose money if I had like an
attorney yeah I don't want you to I
don't want you to pay a dime right now
but I think we need to escalate this
with the apartment and go this is a
Bleaker situation than you guys realize
especially if there are other units if
they're if they're if it's one of two
things if they're like hey we're full we
don't have any other units then I could
see them trying to figure you know
trying to hold that over you or if
they're like we don't have any
comparable units to the the one that
you're in you would have to upgrade or
pay the difference or whatever that is
but if you know for a fact that there's
open units then you've got to push push
push push because the fact is you do
have a baby and this is not good no
one's going to try to tell me that this
is okay for your baby to inhale
especially at the point where it's in
the smell of your clothes you guys have
to show up for work yeah this is a real
thing so I would keep pushing very very
very hard um don't stop paying rent
because the moment you stop paying rent
then you're putting yourself in a a
legal you know a bad legal footing but I
keep when did your lease
up so we we just mov in we moved in
three weeks ago oh man so it's going to
be 12 months 12 months Le that's not
going to work we need to find a
different situation either they need to
let you out of this lease for free or
they find you a different unit now in
the or else this is going to be
escalated in the meantime while you're
pushing through this is there something
you can look at by way of like an air
purifier that you can keep in your you
know at least in the baby's room
somewhere to to work through the air in
your own
apartment yeah so right now we're kind
of uh basically just like sleeping in
the living room because we cannot even
get into our Master room or like nothing
at all oh my gosh and they tell us we
can put a like a blanket over no uh
somewhere in the have they walked into
your apartment yet not going to work has
the staff walked you need to say you're
coming with me right now into this
apartment yeah so they said that
maintenance walk around the apartment
they smell some they smell the weed but
they couldn't figure out who it was so
there's nothing like figure out who it
is I thought we just talked about
they've had a meeting about it and this
person is you know not committing any
crimes here and they can't do anything
yeah this doesn't sound right you know
exactly who it is yeah have you
confronted the neighbor I was going to
ask that so they told us not to because
they don't so they said not to because
they don't have any problem they're
trying to figure out who it is because
they did smell it on the cuz there's
like only six uh people in this like
right now in this uh building well that
narrows it down if exactly so they said
they send a letter to all six of us but
they still don't know who it is only
only you can only you can judge whether
you would feel comfortable doing this
but if I had an idea of who it was I'd
probably approach them and I'd say I
have a young baby and your habit is is
really making it difficult for us and
the landlord I'm working on it because
you you deserve to have your life and I
deserve to have mine but yeah is there
any way that we can that you can work
with me until I'm able to work with them
to get moved is there any way that you
can help me out with this and it look
they might decide to be like you know
who are you I I care less you know and
that's that you know but it can't hurt
to ask if you feel comfortable even
speaking with them and if they were me I
mean I'd ask nicely I wouldn't get in
their face and be like look not a
confrontational situation and I think
there's something about being like I've
got a young how old's your
baby eight eight-month old I have an
eight-month old and my eight-month-old
is waking up coughing to the smell of
your marijuana can you please help me
out I would I'd be reading that lease
agreement I'd be looking up the laws in
your county in your state to go what are
the protections to provide a clean
environment if I'm a renter here paying
this bill and uh if they're not making
good on that they're going to have
problems yeah and so this is your time
to start reading the fine print and
potentially working with a lawyer to
settle this thing and I hope you can
remedy it or at least get out of there
and find a different apartment I'm so
sorry you're dealing with this item
honestly I'd reach out item if I were
you I would start reaching out to my
friends in my network I'd be like who in
my friend group is a lawyer whose
brother-in-law is a lawyer whose grandma
is an attorney I and I'd be like can you
just ask is what would they charge me
just for them to write me this letter
this this threat basically um to help me
out and and find out without really
getting involved just something that's
going to make them feel like oh we got
to move and we got to do this quickly um
so that you can Bluff but not really
Bluff your way into getting this done
faster that's what I would do if I were
you uh I hate that that's happening but
thank you for the call that's crazy and
one last solution is if you ask the
neighbor and say listen there's a shared
wall here the room you're smoking in can
you at least go smoke in a different
room that doesn't have a shared wall and
ventilation so that we can at this
problem and if they're uning to do that
then we got to escalate this that's just
a terrible situation what is wrong with
people I don't know what's wrong I me
some common decency common decency the
thing is like you don't know if it's
medicinal like it's I don't want to say
it's probably not but it's probably not
there's a lot of people skirting that
law I think we can all agree there
skirting that law but it's I agree with
you George I would try everything I
could if I thought it was them I come
over i' be like I have this air purifier
you know if you can just smoke next to
that that would help me a lot so my my
8-month-old I would be trying everything
I would go like I said to my parents to
my friends anybody be like do you have a
friend who's a lawyer that can just look
at my situation right quick because I
think we all know somebody that knows
somebody right it's just like one or two
degrees away that would be willing to
help out in a situation like that o I'll
tell you this Jade I I don't miss the
days of renting apartments me either was
for a season me either I hope that they
can get that sorted out soon cuz that
really stinks but let's let's kind of
try to shift the mood here George
because thank you we need that that was
a downer let's go to an upper if you
will cuz I want to talk to these people
about the ramsy Christmas Cash giveaway
there we go all right that's that's
that's more like it ramsy cash giveaway
is here I'm talking about Christmas Cash
guys we are giving away
$5,000 which is a lot of money
especially when you're trying to get
your Christmas shopping done but the
best part is you can enter the win every
single week and every week we're giving
away $500 so it's like leading up to it
you get 500 500 500 and then if you win
you get the grand prize of 5,000 and
real people win this stuff J real people
yes I see our team get to contact them
and it's a lot of fun that's awesome so
all you have to do is go to ramsy
solutions.com
giveaway and that's where you can enter
like I said enter every week to win 500
and then at the end you'll be put in the
drawing to win the
$5,000 I love that and we got the $12
sale going that's right while you're at
there check out the2 solutions.com store
we've got some of our bestselling books
on there including some new arrivals
like Jade's new book money's not a math
problem my new book Breaking Free from
broke Rachel's got a wallet in Navy it's
beautiful the 2024 gold planner all
kinds of things Ramy solutions.com store
that's right all right thanks for
hanging with us that does it for this
hour of the ramsy show come back and
join us for the next hour of the Ramsey
Show we'll see you
there
[Music]
n
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Jade warshaw I am
joined by George Campbell and the two of
us will be your hosts for today give us
a call the number is8 8 825
5225 those phone lines are open
Christian will screen your call and we
will talk to you about what's going on
in your life and just to be clear this
is a money show but um it intersects
with so many things in your life your
career your marriage your relationships
so many issues are affected uh with your
money and so we understand that so give
us a call we'd be happy to talk with you
about that let's go straight to the
phone lines where we've got Joe in
Jacksonville Florida what's going on Joe
hey I was calling in I was wondering um
how do I go about dating when I come
from an affluent family um you know many
girls parents will see me as a big
dollar sign instead of seeing me for who
I am and I was wondering I was wondering
what your thoughts are because I faced
that problem with many families is how
do they know that's what I was gonna
say um you know usually when you meet a
girl's parents they ask you what your
parents do for work which is a very um
normal thing to ask somebody and then
when you tell them you come from yeah
can we ask you what what do your parents
do for
work um well it's more of my family um I
I have multiple cardiologists in my
family between my cousins and everyone
okay so that's uh and that's your
leading talking point when you're on a
date I don't understand how your whole
family comes up in this
situation well well um not when you're
on a date but when the girl brings you
around her parents and what's your okay
so what's your family's net worth like
just your immediate family what's the
net worth of your
parents um it's
substantial 10 million 20
million uh yes okay so I would not have
garnered that just from you talking to
me I would have thought oh they're
doctors that's great
um if if if I said to you Joe what do
your parents do and you said oh they're
in the medical field and I said really
oh well what do they do in the medical
field if you said oh my dad's a heart
surgeon and my mom's a
anesthesiologist real talk I would be
like okay they got some coin like I
would just derive that but I don't think
that I would even think to ask further I
wouldn't go really so how has that
calcul so how are they getting to the
point of knowing does your family have a
name that people recognize
in the community that's correct yes in
Jacksonville Florida okay so is there a
name on a hospital or something like
that yes yes it is I see okay so it's
much more obvious than you having to
bring it up and talk about it exactly
that's well what does the the family
have to do with it what is your fear
going into this they see you as a dollar
sign what does that mean to you well it
just really uh worries me because I have
to wonder what they're telling what you
know the girls parents are going to tell
their daughter when I'm not around um
you know what um like don't let him go
make sure you do you know I get it I get
it taking taking more interest in me
than other other people
yeah H well I think you're going to need
some discernment as you date to just go
is her heart in it would she have
married me if if my family was broke is
that really a big factor how are you
finding these dates
currently um well you know just around
town in church things like that you know
I try to stay off the internet but you
know that's kind of this day and age
yeah so the people in your church um
they must know your family yes yes
that's correct so there's part of this
that there's part of this that could be
very real and there's part of this that
could be perceived right because uh if I
go back if I go to my home church people
know oh Jade she works for Ramsay she's
on the Ramsey Show like she has this
cool job but it doesn't really change I
could talk myself into thinking they're
going to see me different and they're
going to talk to me different but it
doesn't really change anything cuz
they've been knowing me for how you know
10 years however long I've been at the
church so is there a piece of this that
you're just worried about it or have you
seen it play out and actually be a
reality
um there was
um an instance where I was talking to a
girl at a wedding that I had met and the
father wanted to get his daughter and
and leave the wedding everybody was
leaving uhhuh and he asked uh the groom
what my name was and he told the father
my name and the father said okay well
we'll just wait around and give them a
minute to talk to each other weird I
mean that's weird but that's also like I
feel like there is you should expect for
there to be some like jerk moves or you
know dumb people are going to have dumb
moments for sure but I definitely don't
want that to talk you out of dating a
really nice girl and because here's the
thing you're whether wealthy or not
you're going to go down the
line with plenty of girls thinking I
like I liked her and then it's not going
to work out regardless of having wealth
you might get to the point of thinking
this is the one and then it doesn't work
out I think that that's happened to
everybody right and so I think that
you're going to know pretty early in
whether someone has ulterior motives or
not and maybe that's you developing kind
of your own spidey sense spidey sense or
a little scre a little sneaky screening
test that you do when you're talking to
people and or there's a little checklist
of red flags that you look for when
they're talking to you are they talking
about money in a way that you think is a
red flag are they talking about are they
asking you more questions um about your
family than they're asking about you
right I think it's you going okay what
what is it that I need to be looking for
um when I'm going on dates also who is
it like if if somebody is setting me up
who do I trust to say oh I have a friend
you know they'll be you know cuz I do
think that um I think that the circle of
people that you get in is really
important because people know each other
right and it's like at my church the
folks that I roll with at my church they
know people and I know that the people
they know are good people and then I
since those people are good people it's
like it's almost like birds of a feather
flocking together true and so I would
probably just decide like hey I Pro I
don't
really there's certain people that if
they say hey I have somebody I'm going
to set you up on a date with I'm like
okay no thank you you know yeah I also
wonder if he got out of his own Circle
uh Joe would that help because they
don't know you from Adam at that point
that's also good you know to where
they're they're seeking you out for the
right reasons and my is that it's going
to be more paranoia in your head of like
oh gosh they're trying to get up the
family's money and they don't really
care about me and that's what I don't
want you to have I would just walk into
it and just be Joe and take things slow
ask the right questions you know
establish boundaries be transparent
that's the best thing you can do in
these situations and over time you'll
Vibe it out and you go no that's a good
family those are good parents they're
not out my money and that that's always
going to be a factor though you know
yeah Rachel Ramsay when she was in
college and met Winston Winston was like
like Dave who's that guy yeah and so
that was a big factor of there was no
weirdness there yeah I think honestly I
think a lot of it could be in his head
right now he had that one moment that
like kind of freaked him out and that
can definitely give you make you gun shy
but my guess is most people are not
looking at they're not most people
probably aren't making that connection
they're just like oh your last name is
Jude that's great I'm not thinking St
Jude it must be them this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
a
you're listening to the Ramy show I am
Jade warshaw joined by George camel
Breaking Free from broke is the name of
the book that George camel just came out
with it's very very cool and you're
recording the audio book as well George
that's awesome I just wrapped it the
team's editing it right now and we're
doing an enhanced audio book so it's got
some music transitions we're weaving in
some conversations and phone calls and
things we've done to just spice it up
for the listener I love love that that's
very very cool I try to break the mold
Jade you know I'm excited for that
because you've I've heard your audio on
a couple of different projects remember
when you did the fine print that was one
of my favorites that narrative you got
thank you I appreciate that you got a
good voice for that you have a new book
uh money's not a math problem that just
launched this week on pre-sale and it's
coming out in December so I'm very
excited for you you can check out all of
those books at ramsy solutions.com store
and of course we bribe you with some
goodies for buying it early including
with mine the the free audio book and
ebook now that you told me it's going to
be like Jed up I'm kind of you jealous
you can there's still time to J maybe a
little bit I I do my own sound
effects that's pretty good let's go to
elain did I say that right Elaine in
Phoenix Arizona she spells it
differently what's going on
Elaine uh so I was planning on retiring
next year at 45 um I'm 44 now uh had a
few Financial setbacks uh over the two
years and just kind of wanted to double
check my math that it still makes sense
to leave my 9 to five so wow okay um
leaving the 9o5 can I can I ask a
question are we leaving the 9 to-5 to do
something else or you're just like I am
done using my energy to do any sort of
work I'm the type of person I'll always
do something whether that is going to be
something that's super monetarily
rewarding is sort of to be determined
okay so how much do you have on your
nest
egg uh so I have about
500,000 in various retirement accounts
and then some investment accounts um I
also have about
250,000 that's coming to me from the
sale of a an old primary residence
that'll be added to that um I own my
homes I don't have a mortgage I own my
car I don't have a car payment I don't
have any significant sources of other
than the fact that I have a child who is
you know a huge Money Pit um love him
but huge Money Pit what's your personal
home uh 640,000 okay and you live in
Arizona okay so what's your game plan
let's say you retire next year what is
your game plan and why do you feel like
it's now set
back uh so I went through a pretty nasty
divorce um last year it cost about
180,000 over the two years that we were
in court um um and then I got laid off
last year as well so I had about six
months of no
income um so really I just want to spend
some time and focus on my kid and watch
him grow up and I had some health
complications as well so just slow down
so that I can be here longterm for
him okay and then what's your plan
financially let's say you retire next
year what is the game plan as far as
using these retirement accounts and the
cash that you have to sustain yourself
cuz what if let's say you live to 95
that's a 50-year retirement what's our
plan to not run out of
money
so if IA will not live to 95 our DNA is
terrible but um say that don't say that
don't say that they're doing God will
now spite You by making you live to a
100 well what percentage were you
planning to pull off of
this um so I've been running various
retirement calculators um and basically
drawing down um 45,000 a year
um until I retire and you're working
alone or are you working with a
professional uh I'm working alone I
would strongly strongly strongly
strongly advise you to get with a
professional matter of fact I'd love if
uh Christian can you set her up with one
of our smart Fester Pros set her up with
that information so you can find a pro
in your area because I want you to sit
down with somebody who's going to run
these numbers with you every single
possible way they can run them and
actually be able to give you a number
that has been tested to say hey here's
here's realistically what you could do
and hopefully never touch the principle
of this and CU I'm sure I I think that a
number does exist for that but I just
don't want it to be you doing some quick
calculations based on something you saw
on the internet like and I'm not trying
to be ugly I'm just saying I want to
make sure that this is the right move
but bigger than that I do think that
before you pull the trigger on this I
think you need to know what's next on
the corner for how you're using your
time and I know you have a kid and kids
take up a lot of time but as far as
productivity and how you want to spend
your days and what what you do with your
very very useful to the World
skills okay and I think my hope is that
it that will come once I'm able to sort
of focus and rest a little bit um that
will my purpose will become clear what
if you called this hey I'm going to take
a year I'm going to take one year and
versus I'm going to retire early that's
a very different decision to make that I
think would give me some peace if I'm in
your shoes I got suckered back into
going to work I tried that um I was
going to take a year off and I made it
four months and somebody pulled me back
in what kind of work did you
do uh I'm in software um so I do like
software architecture do you love that
work I used to I hate it now okay so
much because you just did the most for
so for you just I've been doing this
since I was 20 years old I've been doing
this my whole professional life and it's
just it's the same problems every day um
I just want to solve a different problem
I guess what would it I'm I'm just we're
just talking at this point I'm not what
would just a career shift look like for
you to be like you know what I did that
I don't want to be in software anymore I
want to you know sew blankets like
whatever whatever it is that you've just
decided this is what you know what I'm
saying like taking the time to just
spitball things matter fact Christian
make sure she gets kins get clear
assessment and some of those goodies
maybe even paycheck to purpose cuz
here's here's my thing Elaine I really
don't want you stepping out into this to
to nothing else I want you to know like
even if you called and said hey um I'm
going to retire early my church really
needs somebody to lead this initiative
and it's going to give me the time
that's what I want to focus on like I
never heard something that you're
stepping into and I'm not going to lie
that b bothers me a little
bit okay I mean I guess I'm stepping
into being present for my kid because
I'm I can't be right now I work so many
hours yeah um and I know that only lasts
for another probably 10 years until he
hates me and um lives in his room and
never speaks to me again but how old's
your kid how old is how old he's only
four okay look I respect that I'm not
mad at that being a stay-at home mom is
full-time job so I'm not going to uh
dispute that one bit so look get with
somebody talk with them make sure to run
the numbers and see what it really will
take and look I'm proud of you I'm not
mad at all I'm super proud it's not
every day George that someone calls and
says yeah this is an impressive
situation she's 44 has $1.4 million net
worth that's just what the number she
threw out and realistically she could
make these numbers work for a long time
but I do want to make sure that it's
invested the right way that will help
this money sustain itself for a long
Peri of time now 50 years I don't know I
I think we may have to go back to work
eventually we've seen that from the this
is fire financial Independence retire
early and we've seen some some members
of that Community go oh gosh I retired
at 34 and we had it you know $700,000
and now we're running out and also I
need to save for Junior's college and I
don't have an income and so they're
starting to get panicked and worried
inflation housing everything's going up
over time so we have to be cognizant of
what the next 10 20 30 years could look
like I read a article recently and don't
quote me on this because I literally
skimmed the article but it was one of
the founders of fire I think went back
to work for those very reasons it was
like hey I got kids going in college and
this is not necessarily what it was
cracked up to be don't quote me on that
but go see if you can find that article
cuz I do remember reading it thinking
wow that's interesting but for me the
bigger piece of it George
is um being productive with now don't
get me wrong this is not towards Elaine
if elae is like I have a four-year-old
and I'm going to sa with my
four-year-old
she like you know life is more important
than just work I want to watch my K grow
up I think that's a very Noble thing to
do espe after what she's been through
now as a single mom going through a
messy divorce I think she does need some
time to grief yes but do we need to call
it quits and never work again I don't
know that that's the solution right I
mean based on her job alone and based on
the fact of how in demand she was for
her job she has a major contribution
just with her mind doesn't have to be
software but she's got something that
she can do you know once her kid goes to
college like said when he's ready to
lock himself in his room done so I'm
proud of you Elaine hear us say very
very very good job impressive this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
you're listening to the ramsy show I am
Jade warshaw George camel is sitting to
my right and we are your host for the
day give us a call we'll talk about your
life and your money or the things that
are affecting you regarding your life
and your money the number is 8825
5225 give us a call and we will help you
sort it out let's go straight to the
phone lines where we have Stuart in
Billings Montana what's going on
Stuart hey there uh thanks for taking my
call um I'm kind of at a crossroads
right now in my life I just uh had to
put my two weeks in for my current job
um been kind of miserable there um in
insurance and I've been looking into um
taking an online boot camp to be to
start a new career in data science or
data analytics but part of the problem
is that um that obviously has a tuition
cost incurred and I have um existing
student loan debt for my undergraduate
degree and some other miscellaneous
credit card debt that I've been working
on how much
and um grand total is just close just
have 60,000 I've got 35 in student loans
and the remaining um credit cards and
other personal loan debt okay
um so what would it cost to do this data
science degree or certification
or the boot camp I think roughly is uh
9700 if it's paid in full um there's
other there's several different programs
out there that have a variety of costs
it ranges I'd say somewhere between 8
and 15,000 depending on the program but
the one I'm looking at in particular
they claim to have a a 90% job placement
rate and um 100% money back guarantee if
you don't find a job within the first 6
months after completion and you just pay
the the flat rate it's not like hey this
is over the course of three months and
you pay this at this month and this
month it's just a flat the flat cost if
you pay in full is 9700 for the one I'm
interested in otherwise you can Finance
it or um making an installments no we
don't want to do that um how long is the
boot camp it's uh 16 weeks 16 we boot
camp and during the time of the 16 we
boot camp um you're not able to work or
do anything else are you going on
location somewhere is is it online how
does it work it's online it's they say
the average workload is 20 to 25 hours
it's self-paced um so you can actually
work full-time so I could theoretically
go find any other job um and work
full-time in the day and then do this at
night sounds like you would need to how
are you going to pay for the
bills yeah um that's a great question I
I was thinking about trying to find a
different full-time job and also working
part-time on the side but I I'm also
trying to figure out how I can make all
that happened um but I think the bigger
concern was that I just wasn't um going
very far in the current career I was in
and needed to find something that I
could actually um enjoy going to work to
do and I think something in this data
science field would be right up my alley
just a matter of how do I get there how
old are you I'm 28 have you
um um I I I like how you're thinking in
the way of you're like I I started this
job and I'm not going anywhere I don't
enjoy it I think I might enjoy this I'd
like to get I'd like for you to get a
little bit more clarity on why you think
you might enjoy it before you invest
976 weeks um and maybe that looks like
finding somebody who does it and
interviewing them um just digging into
it a little bit more like can I Shadow
you for it like what does your job look
like and really dig into it um we're
going to give you kins get clear
assessment cuz I really want to make
sure that this really is the right field
for you um but let's put that on pause
for a quick moment because what I really
think no matter what you decide to do if
you're like no Jade after further
research I know 100% I want to do this I
think that's great but I do think that
you'll feel better about it if we can
start cleaning up this initial debt in
the process or a first so what would it
look like for you to find a job um that
pays what you are making or
more that's a great question um I mean
for context uh I was I was uh netting
2700 a month after taxes and deductions
and had full health care coverage and a
matching 401K so it's hard to find
something exactly like that right now um
at least and right now you have no
income no i' I'm I've still I still have
about two and a half weeks left of of
working there I I just put in my notice
and um and that's just because you could
not work another day you were like I'm
fed up with
this that and some other circumstances
that I can't really get into but it's
just like ethical stuff it wasn't a
great
yeah not from my own side of things just
wasn't enjoying what I saw on the inside
and um I just was having a hard time
with my mental health getting through
the days and I just knew that this was
the right choice to move on to something
different what's your undergrad
in political science political science
okay yeah well I would do if I were you
is I would be focused right now I would
be getting on glass door I'd be getting
on everything and I'd be looking for a
job that seems like something that you
could stomach or enjoy for the next two
years year and a half sure where you're
making I I want you to get to
40,000 right yeah okay and as much as
you can as much as you can but I want
you matching what you were making before
and I want you to get this debt cleaned
up and in the meantime if you can't land
that full-time job we got to get enough
side hustles to create $2,700 in take
home pay that might mean delivering
people packages food instacart Uber Eats
door Dash Uber lift you name it in order
to bring in enough income to sustain
your life right now until you land that
next job but I'm with Jade I would pause
on this I love this dream of doing data
science but let's pause let's find
something sustainable and let's clean up
some of this debt and then we can cash
flow this $110,000 program and hopefully
increase our income and do something we
love very very good thanks for the call
Stewart that was uh you know not easy
but I think he needs to clean up his his
mess first let's go straight to rob in
Dallas Texas what's going on
Rob hi good afternoon thanks for taking
my call no problem I'll start by saying
I'm on baby step four five and six and
I've been working through a question
with my smart buer Pro we have about
$112,000 that um I got as a bonus at
work to invest towards potentially at
529 which I've already invested in okay
I'll start with my question based on
Lamy principles why is the
529 a better idea than Prepaid College
well and I have some specifics for kind
of our scenario well for me the reason I
like a 529 is because there's no limit
on how much you can contribute to it so
for me that's great and there's not an
income limit um of what you can or can't
make in order to contribute to it so I
just think it's a little bit free Freer
in that sense um and with the 529 you
you don't want the prepaid you want
something where you're able to choose
the Investments and the Investments are
growing and something I like about the
529 is their state specific but you
don't have to choose the one that's in
your state so you can literally work
with somebody to find one that has the
perks that make the most sense for you
so I just feel in general there's a
little bit more freedom in it um but
that being said there's not a right or
wrong answer in your case if you're
wanting to contribute more um than what
a
um contribute more a 529 would be good
for you more than what driv you to the
prepaid
option well thank you for asking so I
have two uh kids and I have 70k saved
for my oldest child and 34 in a 529 in
good growth stock mutual funds my smart
Vestor Pro estimates that at an instate
Public School in Texas uh the younger
one would cost
162k when they turn 18 and 144k when
they uh the older one turns 18 right now
I can take
66k and hand that to the state of Texas
and buy four years of prepaid tuition I
wouldn't do the prepaid option I would
do something where you're able to choose
the funds that are invested in and have
a little bit more control going get
return with that for sure and there's a
lot of restrictions with these prepaid
plans that make them not as great deal
as you think you can't pay for books
housing's off the table there's some
restrictions on what schools you can go
to I don't think you can transfer it in
as many cases right as you would with
the yeah I I would look into all the
fine print on these but we don't suggest
a prepaid plan I'd stick with the 529
and 162 is a lot let's try to get some
scholarships grants and maybe choose a
more affordable school I love that this
is the ramsy
show
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show thank you for
listening uh I am Jade warshaw your host
this is George Campbell sitting right
next to me your other host for the
remainder of the show today uh give us a
call the phone lines are still open the
number is
88255 225 our scripture and quote of the
day each one of you should test their
own actions they can take pride in
themselves alone without comparing
themselves to someone else for each one
should carry their own load that's
Galatians 6: 4-5 Freddy Mercury oo lead
singer of one of the greatest bands I
must say queen and on my top list of
best male vocalists fight me if you want
to 100% he said someone will always be
prettier someone will always be smarter
someone will always be younger but they
will never be you come on somebody
that's what I'm talking about that's a
word that's a word that is oo love that
I had to let that marinate for just a
moment that was good all right let's go
to TJ he's in Philadelphia PA what's
going on
TJ hi I'm fine thank you for taking my
call you're welcome thanks for calling
how can we
help so we are just now starting baby
step two I've been learning about the
Ramsey process and we are in a bad place
from stupid stupid mistakes um we're
just now starting baby step two okay I
have all the numbers for you but the the
question is my husband is um starting to
work overtime and is also working a
second job and he's worried about
missing basically the lives of our two
little kids for working so much for the
next three years yeah um that look
that's a real concern that people have
and it's one of those things where
you've kind of got to weigh both sides
of it and find the right balance in the
middle because your family is extremely
important having time with them is
extremely important and getting out of
debt is important and setting them up by
way of setting yourself up for the
future is extremely important so let's
lay out these numbers and then let's see
if we can help you strike the right
balance in in getting this thing done
fair enough okay yeah so what are the
numbers what's the
debt okay um so like I said we're trying
to turn over a new Leaf here we have IRS
debt we have um 2023 taxes that we
procrastinated on that we need to save
up for $5,000 that okay we have my
student loans for
$6500 okay and then we have back IRS
debt for
$122,000 and that's the back de okay and
then and then student loans for
$24,000 so okay student loans for 6,500
and six and student loans for
24,000 yes okay anything
else that's all no credit cards no car
loans nope no credit cards we we we
broke those up okay how many kids do you
have two two and what is your combined
income with you and your
husband it's
74,000 and do both of you
work no I'm a stay at home mom with the
children how old are the
kids AG is two and my daughter is three
months old okay so this is not as bad as
I thought it was going to be when you
first started talking I was waiting I
was waiting for it to be different so
maybe that makes you feel a little bit
better I don't know maybe it doesn't but
um I'm looking at this and automatically
I'm going to tell you to put the IRS
debt the back debt first that 12,000
even though it's we always say do your
um debts from smallest to largest in
this case the IRS always comes first so
because you've got the back debt let's
do the 12K first and then do the 5K so
12K IRS debt 5K IRS debt then we're
going to tackle the 6,500 student loan
then the $24,000 student loan so that's
the order of importance next things next
let's talk about this budget are you on
a
budget um yeah I I mean I like to just
write down everything on paper but yeah
we're going to change all that today we
are going to rock your world TJ because
we're going to make sure you are set up
with the best budgeting tool out there
it's called every dollar and and it is
going to make your life you're going to
walk away today and you're going to go
oh thank God because tonight you're
going to log in and you are going to
create your budget and you're going to
know by the time you go to sleep tonight
okay like after all the bills are paid
after all the Necessities are paid for
this is how much money that we should
have left at the end of the month and
then I do have a number for you if you'd
like what is it um
$1,400 is what's left and that's with
overtime the second
job yes and with beans and rice type of
stuff okay what's your grocery
budget um I combine Gas and Grocery at
$500 for the month oh that's combined
gas and groceries girl I'm hoping are
you guys investing at all right
now does he have a retirement plan at
all well he's just starting a new job so
he's planning on not investing right
away we want to do that after we got I'm
just wondering where the 74s th000 is
going to figure out how we get more than
1400 cuz 1400 bucks a month that's less
than 17 grand a year and you're sitting
there with you know 47 grand of debt and
that's going to just that's too long to
sacrifice for four five years we need to
speed this up what's your mortgage what
do you pay every month in your
mortgage
1090 okay that feels reasonable
yeah well I think and this is just me I
think that you might I I you will
benefit from dollar and I think you
might find areas where some money is
slipping through the cracks where you
can go okay maybe this is it because
what here's the thing with pen and paper
you're not doing things in real time
you're always having to Circle back and
go okay what was that okay what was that
we're with every dollar every single day
you're getting that update of this is
how much money I can spend so that's
still going to be very a very big deal
but what I really want to get to is
finding a way with side hustles in order
to bring this number up I want you at
least I mean what would would it look
like for you to bring in $500 and your
husband to bring in an extra $500 every
month what would that
take um yeah I I thought about getting a
job myself but he said that he didn't
really want me to work he wanted me to
be a home with the kids that might be
the true
but if if you're not going to work then
he has to do double the work so is he
willing to do double the work it sounds
like he's concerned about that because
the whole Crux of this call was he
doesn't want to miss out on the kid's
life you're at home with them all day so
maybe there's a piece of that that you
can take off his plate is what I'm
saying okay and I think it sounds like a
lot but George and I talk to people all
the time who side hustle they do
instacart and they're bringing in four
and five and6 and $800 a month I even
know people now let me go on record on
saying I don't know if you're supposed
to do this but I know people who take
their kids and do their instacart oh
yeah
and have one car you said you only have
one car yes then maybe it's you drop
your husband off at work then you go do
your instacart shift you go back home
the kids take a nap you do another
instacart thing and then you go pick him
up I think there's a way that you guys
can do this where it's not he hasn't
seen the kids in three years like we
don't want it to be like that we want
you to um that was my Titanic voice by
the way you there's a there is a balance
that you can strike here and I do think
that it's with you picking up some hours
in the day taking the kids with you
and because I don't want him to work 24
hours a day you know I want him to be
able to see these kids I mean you got
two and three-month old the truth is a
lot of people will spend the next 30
Years with Stress and Anxiety and the
kids watch their parents grow up
fighting about money because they didn't
want to sacrifice for those two or three
years while they were young and uh I
don't remember anything you know third
grade I think is my first memory Jade so
truthfully he while he's going to have
the guilt of I'm missing out on all this
the kids are not going to have trauma
because Dad worked overtime when they
were two and I want to set you guys up
for a great financial future for the
next 30 Years 40 years and I'm okay with
sacrificing right now to get there and I
think Jay's right there's a balance I
think you have some skin in the game and
truthfully being a stay home mom is a
choice and that choice comes with
consequences and one of those is we
don't have two incomes we have to figure
something out to clean this up and this
isn't forever and the good news is
here's what I want to leave you with the
good news is you are the average like
you are the person the average person is
out of debt in two years or less you're
that person you guys are going to get
your income up you're going to have
$2500 of disposable I'm throwing at debt
money and you're going to make this gone
you're going to pay off uh $30,000 a
year and this is going to be gone in two
years an extra $500 or th000 bucks
changes this whole
situation dramatically so hang on the
line we will get you every dollar
premium and also sign up for a webinar
Rachel is doing everydollar.com
budgeting in just a few days she's going
to walk you through how to use this
thing oo love it all right guys that
does it for this hour of the Ramsay show
remember you can tell me that you won't
do it but please don't try me by telling
me that you can't with Jesus Christ all
things are possible this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show
a